earlier this week Sotheby's auctioned
off a landscape painting called
Baumgarten by the Austrian painter
Gustav Klimt for a record-breaking 59
million dollars it's incredible
yes Gustav Klimt Garten fifty nine point
three million dollars as it turns out we
have a self-taught expert on Austrian
art here on our staff
it's our prop master built all ya here
to weigh in on the recent sale of bound
garden is built all bill fifty nine
million bucks that's a lot of money for
an old Klimt I gotta be honest pill I
expected that you'd say a little more
than that I said what I came to say you
don't have to play that clip again bill
that's not up to me
[Applause]
[Music]
hideously complete idiocy
you